all right well anyway the secretary of
defense says now there are no plans to
force american troops
to get the covid vaccine which is an
interesting development so far the
pentagon has been hesitant to release
the exact numbers
on vaccination rates for troops but in
february officials did disclose that
over a third of the military who were
offered the shot
refused to get it listen
our top priority is to defend this
nation
and to protect our interests and today
the most urgent challenge that we face
is covet 19.
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin has all the details on this
developing story from the pentagon hi
jennifer
hi jillian well many see this as a
military readiness issue
defense secretary lloyd austin
encouraged more service members to roll
up their sleeves and get the vaccine
like he did i think armed with the with
the right
information accurate information
troops will make will make good choices
the ceo of blue star families dedicated
to helping military families
spoke to me about their survey last
december
that raised eyebrows at the pentagon
we did our original survey to see how
military families were doing and frankly
we were surprised to find that there was
a
great deal of concern the majority of
military family members and service
members were reluctant to get the
vaccine
and an even larger number didn't feel
comfortable with the idea of giving it
to their children
charles eggleston served 16 and a half
years in the army
three and a half at walter reed after
being hit by a roadside bomb he blew the
whistle about black mold at walter reed
he now has a new mission fighting
vaccine hesitancy among troops and
veterans
i wish i could wrap my brain around and
says sheer apprehension
but it's not even apprehension it's
pretty much stupidity
because if you see people dying in other
countries begging
to have this this device
so they can live another day or live
another year whatever the case is
you should be on board eggleston got the
pfizer shot but his mother rebecca
died six weeks ago waiting for hers
infected by an unvaccinated nurse at her
retirement home in virginia beach
she was just waiting for them to give
her the shot
and she contracted it from her nurse who
was a transport that went from the
inside out who should have been cleared
they should have had some policy or some
protocol
then i'm pretty sure that nurse wasn't
following
if pfizer gets full fda approval the
pentagon may change its mind about
ordering troops to get the vaccine
to protect themselves and their units
jillian
wow an amazing story jennifer griffin
thanks for tracking it we appreciate it
it's interesting john to hear that the
military is not going to require
troops or military personnel to get the
shot but we're now hearing that some
american companies private sector
companies
are forcing their employees to get the
shot before they're allowed to come back
into the office speaking of some of
those policy discrepancies you were
hashing out with dr sapphire
and of course there are a lot of
teachers unions who are now demanding
that all the students be vaccinated
as well you know encouraging people to
take a vaccine
is one thing forcing them to take a
vaccine i think gets into a completely
different realm of things i mean i
happily
volunteered to take the vaccine i know
that you had coveted yeah
at one point so uh you've got a natural
immunity that will last for some time
but i've also been vaccinated seven
months
seven actually today 29 weeks pregnant
so just over seven months
you know no clinical trials but my
doctors both recommended i got the
vaccine so
i did it well again voluntarily one
thing for some people quite another so
we'll see how that goes exactly